la femme et l'europe non plus pour la
politique cette fois mais plutôt pour la
mode ou plutôt pour le style comme le
disait coco chanel il n'y a pas de mode
chanel c'est un style la mode se démode
le style jamais c'est une phrase de coco
chanel
pourquoi est-ce que je vous parle de
coco chanel et bien tout simplement
parce qu'ils hier soir à londres
on a vendu aux enchères chez christie's
la collection personnelle de la grande
couturière française décédée en 1971 un
défilé de mannequins un peu nostalgique
cas suivie pour nous protéger pour cette
vente aux enchères de tailleur et bijoux
ayant appartenu à coco chanel on n'avait
pas fait les choses à moitié il y à un
mois ces six une des plus somptueux
salle de vente grande bretagne et sans
doute du monde avait invité la presse
avec champagne mannequin et tout le
falbala pour présenter robes manteaux
bijoux et sacs en tout 120 pièces ayant
été dessinés porter paraît-il par la
célèbre mode liste des années 30 puis
cinq ans par exemple ce manteau et jupes
de tweed confectionner assure la
présentatrice par coco chanel est porté
par elle lors d'une visite à neiman
marcus au texas en 1954 quelques
soucieuse sont inquiétés de savoir si
ses vêtements avaient réellement été
porté par coco chanel la couturière
ayant l'habitude de déclarer qu'elle
n'avait en tout et pour tout que trois
tailleur un noir un blanc et un bleu
marine et qu'elle est usée jusqu'à la
corde lesquelles dès lors de ses
quelques 35 pièces étaient les plus usés
et avait quelques chances d'avoir
réellement appartenu à mademoiselle et
ne mettons pas payer très cher une robe
portée par dieu sait qui que les
scrupuleux bas et leur réticence de
toute façon tout cela était fort beau en
particulier cet ensemble vous donnez
porté par coco chanel en suisse et en
italie le jour d'une première d'un film
de visconti tant de précision et fasse
le 12 l'ensemble était vendu par liane
brune bac d'abord attaché de presse puis
ami intime de coco chanel et qui avait
gardé tous ses trésors d'élégance depuis
sept ans depuis la mort de la grande
couturière
il y a pas de mode chanel c'est un style
la mode se démode le style jamais disait
mademoiselle chanel
tant mieux pour liliane grunge bac qui
vendait les robes se sont aujourd'hui
rallonger essombé c'est vrai qu'on peut
mettre un channel et sortir il y aura
des clients 300 s'était fait inscrire
pour le jour de la vente pour acheter ce
bout d'histoire de la mode féminine
l'histoire en fait de la libération de
la femme chanel ayant été la première
dans les années 20 à jeter crinolines et
baleines effet dit on sortir la femme de
ses corsets mais pourquoi vendre cette
collection est d'abord à qui appartient
tel bien
en fait à moi quand je pense qu'elle
appartiendra j'espère de la partie à
l'histoire elle appartient
- qu'elle a
son aise dans des musées et des
collectionneurs pour pouvoir continuer
d'exister et pourquoi la vendée vous
précisément
je pense que
on ne doit pas garder ça enfermer les
normands avaient d'ailleurs qu'il
fallait pas que cette collection restent
dans les tiroirs où les armoires mais
elle va partir aux etats-unis dans les
tiroirs où les armoires de riches
américains aux états unis en france aux
états unis en france en angleterre en
allemagne et dans les tiroirs du nom
présent tiroirs elle sera si lyon des
musées et tout le monde pour aller la
nuit pour tout le monde pour aller la
voir quel genre de musée peut être
intéressé par coco chanel ou avoir
l'argent tous les musées suisses en
étant c'est effectivement hier soir un
musée qui emportera la plus belle pièce
vendue 20 mille francs au musée d'oslo
et la connexion va disparaître pour 650
mille francs trois musées achèteront
deux anglais dont le victoria and albert
museum et un norvégien le reste est allé
à de riches américains ou anglais
l'essentiel des robes s'étant vendu et
aux environs de 10 mille francs
c'est à charles plus sympathique lui de
cette jeune fille elle travaille chez
christie's s'est offert au channel pour
samy francs et le portera madame vincent
auriol a été hospitalisé cet après midi
la veuve de l'ancien président de la
république a été victime d'un malaise
elle est âgée de 83 ans